it worked 10 minutes ago ah here it is
okay
um so
thanks all for joining I'm going to
tell something about apacheiro I'm going
to try both
explain Apache arrow for those that are
not yet too familiar as well as show
some yeah newer developments for people
already knowing apachero
quickly about myself I'm an open source
developer almost full-time maintainer of
pandas I'm also involved in the
geospatial stack and so I'm mostly
working nowadays at Apache Arrow more
specifically the python bindings Pi
arrow and I'm doing that at Voltron data
so we are a company building our own
native data analytics
so let's get started with Apache Arrow
so what is Apache Arrow it's many things
but so at its core like the the main
thing is that it's
um has a yeah it specifies or a
standards how to represent columnar data
or tabular data in memory
that's the core specification there are
some additional
specifications around that and then you
have many languages many implementations
in various languages
that Implement those specifications and
so
you can buy
at least in the past you had various for
example virus data frame libraries in r
in Python databases Spark all having
their own custom memory in-memory
formats and so if you want to move data
around from one system to another Au
constantivity copy and convert
serialization deserialization costs and
the idea about Apache arrow is that if
you have this common
standardized memory layout that either
those data frame libraries or databases
just use natively themselves or have
like a very efficient conversion for
then yeah you can much more easily and
cheaply move data around from uh between
different systems
and you can also share implementations
for example parquet reader it's more
much more easily to share such
implementations
it's not only meant for moving data
around the the memory format also meant
to be an efficient in-memory format for
actual processing so it's uh yeah
we call it the columnar format so it's
columnar each column the data of each
column is in a contiguous buffer so
that's in contrast to the yeah
traditional databases that they were
typically row based where you have data
of one row of potentially different data
types together while if you have each
column together
um yeah that's more suited for efficient
vectorization and and
efficient operations this is not
something like new pandas already did
that from the start for example but it's
like the core uh yeah one of the core
ideas of the format that makes it
efficient
um as I already mentioned that's really
the the base of everything in the arrow
ecosystem a few more details about the
format so
um
it's as expected for a standard tabular
data format it supports the right
variety of types
in comparison to the more traditional at
least for the python World array Library
types that that we know
um for example numpy Arrow also supports
a variable size or variable length
strings or binary data nested types for
example where every element in your
column is a list or array or a struct
um it also in contrast with a typical
array libraries has support for missing
values for all data types and it does
Arrow specifically does that by defining
um
bitmaps or basically a separate yeah
mask
keeping track of where you have valid or
missing values
um
and I want to point out that it's
nowadays actually really has become the
yeah really standard and this figure is
a very old figure that was I think it's
yeah six or seven years old but made in
the beginning when our project was
started and at the at the time when the
figure was created this was really the
vision of Arrow that's what they wanted
to achieve and
um yeah nowadays is actually reality I
don't know the uh I'm not super familiar
with all the names on on this on the
sphere but you could certainly make a
similar one with yeah pandas are spark
snowflake bigquery click house they all
use Arrow to uh
interchange data
um
there's a bit of an overview so in the
middle we have the columnar formats
there are some additional specifications
on top of this format so the one that
has been there from the start also is
the IPC
inter-process communication so
you have something in memory but you now
you want to send it to a different
process send it over the network
and so the IPC format is a very shallow
efficient
serialization format but specialized for
our data so that has been there from the
start and later in the talk I will focus
a bit more on the
um on two of the other ones
on top of that you have lots of
implementations in various languages
most of them at least all of them all
Implement at least the core memory
layouts and the the serialization
formats
depending on each implementation you
will also have a a different yeah
level of how much tools that they
provide and actually to actually compute
things on on our data and so if you look
at from a python point of view
so there are some of the arrow libraries
that you can actually use to not just
move data around but to actually do to
do actual competitions so you have the
ROC plus limitation with the pi Arrow
bindings where we have a
compute engine which is called as zero
the error rust implementation you have
the data Fusion projects it's in Rust
but you have python bindings they have a
full query engine
you also have the another arrow
implementation in rust on which spoilers
is based supporters itself is not an
arrow project but it's yeah built on top
of an arrow implementation and so yeah
various implementations of Arrow already
being used nowadays to yeah
in the um to expand the data frame
ecosystem in in Python and for example
also Ibis can then interface with all
those three
Ibis is a is a python library that gives
a data frame interface that has
different backends and they can also use
various backends based on on Arrow
apart from libraries that are really
from the arrow projects there are also
various new newer
systems or compute computational systems
that are very that not don't necessarily
use Arrow directly but are
fully or partly compatible with arrow
for example you have the Rapids project
for gpus on the like the qdf they use
Arrow memory internally duckdb is not
related to Arrow but it's very much
compatible with arrow so if you move get
data in or out.db they will use our
fellows similarly it's a relatively
recently open source project from from
Facebook so basically the the new
compute engine from Facebook they are
not using Arrow directly but they are
compatible so you can easily
um
and because they all use Arrow you can
if you have your tooling and you ensure
that your data is in our compatible
format you can very easily integrate all
those different Tools in your workflows
because of this common memory formats
I myself most familiar with the python
bindings or at least the pi Arrow so the
python bindings to Roc plus
and this package provides yeah a whole
set of of building blocks that are being
used throughout the ecosystem
both for
um yeah just implementing the
specification using it for the the other
serialization
moving data over the network also the
yeah
accessing data on file system different
file formats and so by always
certainly in the in the early years was
mostly used for reading parquet files
nowadays it can do a lot more but that's
still a major use case
reading data sets and so also has a
compute module uh which oh yeah a whole
bunch of computational kernels
um
and yeah this is already now being used
rightly in the in the pi data ecosystem
and for example dusk is using the
um
need data access to read files dusk is
using that a lot and I learned at the
conference that does also started to use
the the IPC serialization in their
distributed Shuffle implementation to
optimize that
um
and another example of Ed where arrow is
being used as a compute engine as well
improving the data frames is pandas so
on Monday Patrick explained
um
or showed a bit how pans is starting to
use Arrow under the hood and yeah you
can find more details in in that talk
um
now
I want to for the rest of the talk go a
bit more in detail on on some of those
aspects and how those yeah things are
working
um
so I've mentioned that
all those different libraries they can
easily share data but so how that
exactly
works is based on one of the other
specification elements that are
mentioned here below and so first I want
to focus on on this one the the C data
interface
um
so as an example
polars
an arrow so I created the small portals
data frame porless has a method to Arrow
to convert it to an arrow table
we could further convert it for example
to pandas data frame or to some other
library but in this case so the data of
those both objects is actually the same
data so that's this conversion is like
zero copy fast conversion
um
and although both are python libraries
the one is implemented in Rust and so
the actual data is under the hood is a
rust object by Arrow under the hood is a
c plus object and they are pointing to
the same data
that might seem trivial but that's
really only possible because of the
standardization uh yeah of the format by
arrow and also by a specification that
they can actually share pointers between
those independent runtimes without that
they have to need without that they need
to be aware of each other so polars of
course imported Pi Arrow under the hood
to create this object but it's not that
spoilers needs to know how the C plus
object is laid out to create it it
doesn't need to compile against the ROC
pass projects and so how that works is
through the one of the specifications of
the arrow project which is called the
the C interface so it's meant for zero
copy sharing of data between
independent libraries between languages
within the same process so that they can
share actual data
it's based on yeah some a few small C
definitions so if you have a language
that can interface with the from
function interface like CFI then you can
work with this and so it allows to yeah
integrate with the arrow format without
necessarily using uh the our software or
relentlessly knowing the other library
that would would like to consume your
data
um
it's used by so I gave the example of
polars but also if you move data from
wb2 to
pandas or or python in general is being
used for data Fusion the same and a
bunch of other libraries are already
using it as well for example to share
data between Python and R it's the same
story
um how does this work it's so that's one
example of of such C definition so it's
a struct
and in the end it's really just
just pointing to some buffers like these
are here you have pointers to buffers
and that is being shared with some
metadata to know how to interpret those
buffers and yeah some additional tooling
to to manage Lifetime and things like
that
there is an array there's also a schema
so the data type is is shared separately
and you have a streaming version of it
as well
um one example that I this dear new to
my heart that I want to show is uh is is
Judo is a yeah most widely used library
for reading and writing spatial data
basically every geospatial software that
does some IO uses gdo it's a c plus
Library
how does it work typically if you want
to use it from python so I'm also
maintaining one of the Python bindings
for digital g-da loads data from some
file format into its own data model and
then it has an API that we can call from
python where we get row by the data row
by row
um but that's yeah has a lot of overhead
it's also a lot of work to implement
this if you want to get the data into
the tabular format and so we can improve
this by
using Arrow there and that's something
that was has been implemented in the
latest version of gdel so they now have
a way that you can that detail directly
creates our data and as the python
Library we can directly receive the data
as Arrow instead of receiving it row by
row and having to build up the data
frame ourselves
digital can then also even optimize it
depending on the the file that they are
reading how to construct this uh the
arrow data
I'm going to skip this a little bit but
so it's also using the C data interface
so that anyone who implements uh can
consume that can directly
integrate with Cheadle and it gives a
very nice speed up apart from just being
much easier to use as a consuming
Library
um it's not always easy to implement
the C data interface yours so for
example gdal did that truly themselves
is like the maintainer is a yeah did a
very nice effort there but
um
to make that easier one project that I
want to mention that a colleague of mine
has worked on a lot is nano arrow and
it's wants to give an easier to
integrate yeah some helper functions to
work with the with this C data interface
so it's a small C library that you can
vendor and so that you don't have to
necessarily
have a The ROC plus post Library which
is a very large Library lots of features
so that you don't necessarily have to
use the that big Library as a compile uh
time dependency we just Can Can Vendor
Nano error
um
and so yeah with the goal of of making
it easier to consume produce data in
this in this format
um
the second thing I want to show that is
relatively new in the arrow ecosystem
and it also Builds on top of the C data
interface is the what is called the
arrow database connectivity or adbc and
so this is about getting data in our
databases and so something that is used
very often
our Protocols are like interface like
jdbc or DBC in Python we could also I
mentioned the python DB API 2.0
but essentially what happens here is
that these are generic interfaces
so as a user you can use those generic
interfaces then you have some driver
that's translates that your query to
something database specific
gets the data out of the driver and then
returns those data to the user
the main problem with those interfaces
are there at the moment
they are all row oriented odbc can do
some color oriented data as well but
it's not very compatible with arrow so
I'm going to leave that aside
um and so yeah
you get data row by row well maybe even
your your database could be columnar and
you want column the data in the end but
you so you have to pay the conversion
cost twice to use those interfaces and
so that's why adbc was introduced
um
and so the idea is very similar it's
also yeah database agnostic interface
so that you can use it with any database
behind the scenes
you again have a driver that translates
your query to a database either you have
a database that is our native and can
just directly return our data or you
could have a driver for example for
proseq SQL that will convert
inside the driver already so you don't
have to do that yourself
convert the row oriented data to
columnar Arrow data and return that to
the user
um
so yeah the the goal of of adbc is to
have a single API to get uh Arrow data
in and out of a databases so that's our
native it's also using the data
interface
um
to not be specific to a certain
implementation of Arrow sender agnostic
or database agnostic
and so yeah defines a common client API
interface uh that virus database or kind
of drivers for various databases and
it's yeah focused on not necessarily to
replace those existing interfaces but
focused on cases where you want columnar
data access
small example how it works in in Python
so there are already some drivers very
initial versions they don't necessarily
Implement everything
there are some available for example for
sqlite and postgresql
and they provide a very
yeah similar API as other
python database libraries so you also
create a connection cursor you execute a
query
but instead of using the typical fetch
one fetch all methods there is a fetch
Arrow table and you get the the data at
once so that's
um
you get the columnar data
we have initial versions but they are
very much so it's only from the yeah
start of this year that is um has been
adopted by our community so it's very
much early stage of those drivers but
just a small example for the existing
sqlite driver so I use spanners to write
a data frame to a sqlite file I read it
through the current version the current
imputation of pandas or I can really
tweet the SQL lights driver and what you
see here is mostly the avoiding the
overhead of that pandas does this role
by row
retrieving rule by row and building up
the data frame in Python
to end I want to mention one more thing
about specifications one that is not
from Arrow itself but very much related
so for example in the in the case of of
adbc you still specify a SQL query to to
indicate to the underlying database or
other data provider
what data you want to retrieve
but yeah SQL
has many advantages being many people
knowing it being very widely supported
but so substrate is a another project
that tries to be in yeah a universal
standard for representing relational
operations and so the idea is that arrow
is the standard for the mem like the
data that you that you retrieve that you
get while substrate is the uh the
standard for to specify which data you
want
um and the the idea is that yeah
currently you can have all kinds of of
interfaces like whether you want to use
python or r or which packets in Python
which packaging are various
possible interfaces you also have lots
of query engines and currently like yeah
each for example Ibis has backends for
like 15 different backends I think while
in principle so Arrow already improves
how data moves between those different
layers and substrate could also improve
how you pass the information like what
do I want to compute
that's a very brief primer on on this
separate
specification so thanks for your
attention
[Applause]
thank you very much for your talk
um also we have quite some questions and
I will just
um yeah start by popularity of those
questions
and um
the first question we have is so pandas
and Spark use Arrow to exchange data but
how does power Pi Arrow serial serialize
data itself
um so
for example the the serialization is
used to move data from from spark to
pandas and the the the serialization
format is essentially
using exactly the same formats as the
memory data like how the data is laid
out in memory and that is and but
putting some metadata around it and in a
in a single buffer but
um by using mostly exactly the same uh
yeah layout as the memory data that
makes it efficient uh yeah for for with
not that much serialization
deserialization costs
now thank you I think this covers the
question as far as I understood uh but
I'm sure you will also happy the answer
questions
um if it was not not precise enough or
you want more detail
um the next question is when I use
pandas or spark does it automatically
use arrow in the background or do I need
to enable this somehow
um for spark I'm not super aware I know
that it depends on the version and that
they are moving to columnar data in more
recent versions but I know don't know
the details there for pandas it's
currently something optional if you
don't use it by default we use it by
default for example for reading parquet
data but we don't use it by default as
the memory representation there is a
d-type back-end keyword in several of
the i o methods that you can specify to
to actually use Arrow
memory for every column but yeah if you
want to know more details there are some
examples in the in the slides that I
that I mentioned from Monday
okay thank you
um
then let me check the next question
[Music]
um
how did Arrow manage to be adopted by so
many libraries usually when you invent a
new standard to unify all of them you
end up with a new competing standard
yeah that's a good question I think it
probably shows that it really filled the
needs and and that it provides a lot of
value I suppose it's mostly yeah mostly
that
so you generally think some there's some
need for unifying Concepts or um yeah
like defying the Sue of tools available
yeah it's certainly from the start I
wasn't there from from the full fully
from the beginning in the arrow project
but it certainly directly provided like
at quite some concrete use cases where
it provided a lot of value for example
the the example of of the
spark and pandas what was mentioned
before moving data from PI spark to to
python if you have like a user-defined
function that was really slow uh some
years ago because they like had a custom
way of sending the data from from the
gvm to to
um to Python and back while
many years ago when they enabled like
using Arrow as the way to send data
around they really improved like
user-defined function in pi spark with
like a huge
amount in performance wise so directly
from the start there are some very
concrete benefits and I think that
certainly helped with yeah showing
Paving the way for broader so coming
from the use case um you would say it's
really a benefit to show show the value
and from there on adjust went its way
yeah
um yes I think we have time for um
one or two more questions maybe
um
maybe I'll pick this one
um how good is the adbc currently and
where are the pitfalls right now
um well I think the
um sqlite is rather feature complete
it's certainly not optimized it's more
mentioned meant for like a Proto like
showcase the posca square driver is
certainly not fully uh
um like not fully feature completed only
supports a limited number of data types
not yeah I don't know them by heart
um but yeah it's it's like it's only
released like a few months ago the
initial uh versions so that's very much
work in progress so I wouldn't say that
those drivers are currently like yeah
they're far from production ready but
it's certainly the the goal to
um yeah
improve those drivers and also that the
hope is that database implementations
will start to provide
drivers for for their database based on
this protocol uh just as yeah all the
other systems are adopting Arrow we hope
that this can happen here as well
thank you very much for your answers
also thank you very much very much for
your questions unfortunately we don't
have any more time so um if there's any
more questions just address yours and
let's thank him one one more time for
his talk
foreign
[Applause]